the attack lasted 20 seconds but the
husband said it took him 3 minutes to
understand what was
happening what what happened to you just
say
[Music]
it all right this uh this thing happened
in Texas it's like a one in a million
situation so this woman got
attacked by a hawk that was carrying a
snake oh [__] damn what the flag of
[Laughter]
Mexico oh [__] I guess everybody
realized it at the same time too and it
C wow this guy knows his flag yeah
you're right it was so the she's like
and the flag's all flapping on her face
so it was never a real hawk or anything
it was just a flag the flag just came
off the pole hit her in the face
apparently uh so she got pretty messed
up from the attack uh so the hawk was
carrying a snake and it dropped the
snake the snake falls out of the sky
onto her arm and wraps around and just
squeezes it oh [__] the hawk is trying
to get the snake back my food yeah yeah
yeah so the hawk is just going c c c
while the snake is like stuck to her arm
damn what are the odds dude i' rather
have bird [__] on me what the [__] yeah
of course CRA Falls bites her hot coms
bites her and like the wrong place wrong
time there's a photo of I'd rather have
50 bucks what the
[__] dude yeah there's like her arm got
so jacked up from it there's no like I
keep trying to find the photos but they
keep blurring it out cuz it looks really
bad like you can see a little bit of it
right there
dude Hawks don't [__] around they don't
dude especially while you have a
tourniquet on your arm I know that too
yeah and she said that the the snake
wasn't letting go obviously it was he's
about to die I'm holding on to you
you're not going to go anywhere right
you're the Safeguard the hawk just takes
off of both of them
yeah I mean she just looks like she
Farms saffron or something and then
she's just chilling in her garden I she
I mean she she looks like Candle Maker
her AR Candle Maker arm shaped she looks
like she has an Etsy yeah yeah dude yeah
it jacked her Arma but that's such a
strange situation where was she at Texas
Mexico like walking outside it's kind of
like a lot of Mexicans a little bit Yeah
I can see the little creep over the
Border dude someone commented God hates
her she's probably a bad person proba
aen she probably made too many
complaints on her neighbors we're all
sitting here what did she do yeah yeah
yeah dude not only that was it a
rattlesnake I don't know if it was a
rattlesnake uh cuz that would be funny
if she was getting bit how they get it
like actually off of her though like if
it's wrapped around and you got like oh
come help me like I wonder how that got
to squeeze the head of the snake or
something said they said too that the
snake actually never uh got a chance to
bite her but I think Venom from the
snake got on in her eye shut the cuz it
as it shoots it right screaming
screaming
she she might be a bad person imagine
being the person to witness that and
she's like help me and you're like what
what's the protocol like wait what stop
dropping roll stop dropping roll right
dude that's like a world star that's
kind of like biblical or some [__] like
I feel like that's out of the Bible
right that's why this dude saying that
you have been
chosen snake V him in the eye a good
omen yeah because they said that they
had to clean it off her glasses she
couldn't put her glasses back on cuz
there's Venom on the lens what do you
think her sin was do you think she's
sitting there going I'll never ask for
the manager ever
again I wanted whipped cream on my
coffee I know it's like I'll
never oh yeah it's not what do you think
what do you think her sin was um uh she
keeps uh yelling at the Starbucks
employees that's what she did no she
looks like a sweet little lady I it's
hard to tell right yeah she looks sweet
enough yeah she's telling her neighbor
not to mow the lawn at a certain hour
because she needs her rest oh yeah oh
god dude that's her sin it's very
specific yeah you can't be watering past
6:00 p.m. or something her name's uh her
name's Peggy Jones oh there I found the
photo show the photo show the photo
pretty bad dude
oh that looks like just
claws that is [__] up yeah that's
rough I was expecting worse actually I
was kind of expecting worse you wanted
to be like gashed open what do you want
you want like bone showing sport well it
just pecks dude you know what I mean
just want like the arm barely hanging
off like bro you got to start punching
birds at that point for sure so as a
martial arts expert how do you get out
of the situation I think the initial
reaction is like oh [__] I'm just doing
this a bunch and then the birds like
stay still [__] yeah I think you got to
[__] I don't know maybe you just got
to punch the [__] out of a bird got like
get
you got to grabb that [__] neck or
something may but then what if the snake
has time to bite you now well you're
already in a [__] [__] position but
the bird on top of the snake is not well
not even a bird the hawk on top of the
snake yeah I'm punching a hawk for sure
you got to punch a hawk in the face I
feel like you got to punch the hawk and
then you got to run so you can deal with
the snake yeah yeah it's one thing at a
time you know yeah punching the hawk cuz
the snake is just in defense mode you
know yeah right the snake is scared just
like you exactly SN scar you you're
going like this on the ground bro Texas
is wild or you're on the ground and then
you leverage your foot with a snake head
and she don't look like she flexible
though too much that's yoga at that
point I think you're going to have at
all costs save the arm yeah yeah yeah
yeah was it the right arm or the left
arm it looks like it's her right arm or
you just open up your car door slam
it so you punch the you do it
simultaneously you punch the hawk by the
snake and pull it off with your
te then the snake like bites you oh that
could happen well you bite the head of
the snake I think from now on she's
going to be she's going to turn this
into a positive and she's going to get
one of those giant hawk gloves that she
can call upon her Hawk every then
whenever she walks outside she's going
to have a giant leather glove once it
heals she needs to [__] tattoo the
snake on her
[__] hey she really there you go and
a big Mexican flag right here so so
here's what her husband says um that he
saw her screaming and running in a
zigzag pattern and he goes my wife is
Goofy and then and then he said and then
I turned the TV back on you want to know
how I know this is okay look this is not
the same situation but I'm going to make
it the same situation sometimes when
Tiff my wife is at home and we're
watching TV and she's cuddling with the
dog and then the dog starts stepping on
her head she's like oh my God please
don't please stop please stop and then
she's like babe can you help me I'm like
just grab the
dog just grab the dog and put him down
she's like no but he stepping on my ha I
can so I have to walk from the kitchen
and take the dog and put in her lap and
with that interaction alone I can
imagine the lady getting bit by the hawk
she's just doing this yeah they're not
addressing the and then the husband's
like
yeah she's just like oh my I just can't
I just can't do this right now it says
that the the attack lasted 20 seconds
and uh but the but the husband said it
took him 3 minutes to understand what
was
happening that's great like what the
[__] is going on what what happened to
you just say it
I yeah cuz he said she was hysterical so
it's like you know you what fell out of
what
Scott what did he see the hawk though uh
I guess he did he was just outside
looking at the window like what the hell
Isen yeah he just saw her running like
running zigzagging and flailing that's
with a HW just on her arm like a movie
or something how does that land on a
person bro also just imagine like waking
up in the morning just be like another
beautiful day going for my routinely
neighborhood walk and just that's what
you run into and then instant snake R
dude that's crazy I was watching this
one but also too it's like the most
random [__] happens to you and you can't
even believe it I was watching this one
video of this guy he was filming a snake
that was on top of his fan a ceiling oh
yeah I saw that you seen that sh and
he's like what the [__] this is crazy
and then the the snake starts looking at
him and then the trajectory it sticks
its head down and it get S Frozen off it
gets whipped seen that how does that
like what are the possibility that's the
view you're like oh how does and the
guy's like oh
[__] that and you're like it just if you
put if you think that could happen
that's going to happen like it just it
just you just never Fu dude God hates
snake is
like yeah yeah like this is fun for me c
this is pretty sad cuz she's talking
about how she has like snake nightmares
Now snake nightmares Yeah it's you're
going to have snake nightmares sometimes
I'm in a room and there's snakes all
over the wall and the ceiling and all
over the floor dude imagine she she had
a she had a vacation with her husband to
Mexico later that year
everywhere she goes she's just in trauma
[__] this flag but you that's why you
got to follow build the [__] wall
that's why you got to watch Nature's
metal bro she just becomes a [__]
racist wait do you hate snakes or
Mexicans
both that combination of a hawk and a
snake so how do you think you get a
Mexican